i've gotten advice in the past to argue
in front of your kids not and not wildly
so that they can see an arc of a
relationship where
this is what a disagreement between two
people who love each other and then the
next morning they're having breakfast
together and everybody's smiling and
laughing
that must be what that looks like right
yes what's the balance between that
i guess that's the balance between that
disagreement versus a
we need to get behind closed doors take
the gloves off yes really angry
and i think specifically if it's about
them
because what will happen is if it's
about them one of you is often going to
be
siding with your child and feeling like
the other parent is being too strict
and so when that happens that's where i
think girls can step into all that freud
stuff
they start owning yeah yeah i'm going to
triangulate myself in here between my
parents
and so i think those are the arguments
that feel more concerning to me
as primarily counselor to girls that
they're going to start to work that
later on
is it true that i hope it's true because
i say it almost every single
show whatever it is
that you you alluded to this kids feel
the ten the relational tension yes and
they tend to backfill that tension with
it must be my fault
and they start trying to solve it in
these ways is that right
yes absolutely okay yeah and they start
solving it
it's been my experience that kids
whether they get into stuff that we've
all said
is not a good idea whether it's they're
gonna run off and make straight a's
they're gonna tuck their shirts in
and they're gonna try to perfect their
body image that really
on the ark is the same behavior it just
we we reward some of it unfortunately
and then it can still pathologize itself
we can still get off the rails there
and then we go to war against other
behaviors but really
they're just trying to i guess it goes
back to being seen but they're just
trying to perform right yes
absolutely and i mean that's you know
with anxiety
right now girls are leading the
statistics and
boys are taken in for treatment more
whereas girls are more anxious
and i think it's because of exactly what
you said i think boys often are more
explosive and so we're seeing their
behavior and it's concerning and girls
who are anxious
they're imploding from the inside out
and they're perfectionistic and they're
doing
great in school and parent-teacher
conferences the teachers say i wish
every child was like her
but we're missing that it's fueled by
the same thing this panic inside of i've
got to live up to the expectations
so how do you man you're going to get me
all fired up here and it's in this mill
a day
so how what do i say as a parent
i know my daughter's not doing well and
the teacher is saying
i you know you can feel your your seven
year old your 12 year old your 14 year
old start to withdraw
yeah they're still they're still
checking the boxes
right they're going to school they're
still getting the grades good enough
you know you're losing your kid and you
can't put your finger on it and you got
a teacher you got a
pastor at some church you've got adults
and their soccer coach saying
i would do anything for for a team full
of those right and then i got
a boy who's a knucklehead and
rambunctious
and so kind and so compassionate and
you can watch them grinding through that
distraction to get their grades
and i've got a teacher saying i don't
want that kid in my class anymore what
how do you how do you equip what would
you equip parents with
to go into those conversations well i
think
i would say trust your gut as a parent
because you're going to have a million
people you see that she's making me look
so smart
oh my gosh dude this is this is
this whole episode everybody's just for
me it's a hundred percent for me
i have a low self-esteem and she makes
me feel better yes okay
yeah i mean i you know your child better
than anybody and
and i think just like with our health
you've got to advocate for yourself
and for your child and so even if it
takes you saying things and putting
yourself
out there and going back over and over
trust your gut and follow it
so as someone who works with families a
lot how many times
do you have your own kids no okay you
don't okay i've counseled thousands of
them over the years but i have a
two-year-old nephew
okay so how would you answer this
question for me then
the longer i go the more i wish i could
walk back
that makes sense how do you teach a
parent to forgive themselves how about
that
the more i i go i go oh gosh i wish i
could have that conversation back or
oh and freaking i wish i could how do
you
not let that pile up as a parent and you
can begin to
discharge that that pain and then move
on right you can't keep carrying that
around with you
well i mean i think it all gets used at
some point
and if this generation of kids
is feeling more pressure than ever
before to be a perfect parent
the fact that you weren't is only going
to help them
alleviate that when they get to their
own parenting and i think
you know again you're younger than i am
but i think so many of us never had
parents who said i'm sorry will you
forgive me and
and they kids today feel so much
pressure to be
perfect and so as their hero for you to
say to them
i blew it i'm sorry will you forgive me
even if it's five years later i've been
thinking about a conversation we had
once
and i wish i'd done that differently
like what a powerful message for them
that validates who values them i think
saying i'm sorry to your kids is the
most important thing you can do is that
fair
yes absolutely it's fair yes